für Polizei und Feuerwehr ist die
Neujahrsnacht längst kein Grund zum
Feiern mehr diese Bilder aus
Berlin-Neukölln zeigen wie Balkons
gezielt mit Leuchtraketen beschossen
werden doch damit nicht genug auch ein
Rettungswagen der einen Patienten zum
Krankenhaus fährt wird angegriffen erst
mit Feuerwerk dann schmeißt jemand deine
zehn Kilogramm schweren Feuerlöscher auf
die Frontscheibe die hält der
Stahlflasche stand die Polizei kann den
Täter festnehmen
Barrikaden werden errichtet in Brand
gesetzt und der schweren die Arbeit der
Rettungskräfte zusätzlich ein
Löschfahrzeug der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr
wird mit seinem Notruf in einen
Hinterhalt gelockt und dann von 25
vermummten überfallen und ausgeraubt
also eigentlich macht mich sprachlos
dass sowas möglich ist
25 vermummte auf dem Feuerwehrfahrzeug
neue Qualität auch in anderen Städten
gab es Angriffe auf Rettungskräfte die
bundesinnenministerin teilt schriftlich
mit das ist ein Ausmaß an Gewalt das
fassungslos und wütend macht und es
zeigt deine Verrohung die konsequentes
Handeln erfordert in Berlin wurden 103
Menschen festgenommen die Rufe nach
konsequenter Bestrafung und gar einem
böllerverbot werden immer lauter
und uns nun zugeschaltet hierzu der
Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der Polizei
Jochen kopelke guten Tag nach Bremen
hallo
worin liegt die neue Qualität wie wir
gerade gehört haben dieser Ausschreitung
wenn er z.B von hinter halten die Rede
ist die muss man sich das konkret
vorstellen
die Polizisten kennen das mit Feuerwerk
beschossen zu werden aus anderen
Einsatzlagen die neue Qualität die jetzt
auch feuerwehr und Rettungskräfte
erleben sind Hinterhalte massiver
Beschuss und eine hemmungslose und auch
unkontrollierte Gewalt die uns
entgegenschwappt und die war
vorherzusehen und leider wurde die
Gewerkschaft der Polizei darin bestätigt
und ich wünsche meinen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gute Besserung Berlin war ganz
besonders betroffen aber auch in anderen
Städten gab es schlimmer Ausschreitungen
was weiß man da über die Täter das
scheint ja doch deutlich über das
hinauszugehen was man sonst über
Teenager sagt die ein bisschen über die
Stränge schlagen
die täterstruktur ist immer ganz
unterschiedlich glaube es wird es viel
mehr an gruppendynamischen Prozessen
festmachen es war klar dass nach der
corona-pandemie ein großer Druck auf der
Gesellschaft zum Feiern und zum
Loslassen liegt und es war klar dass
wenn Alkohol im Spiel ist und frei
verkäuflicher Zugang zu Pyrotechnik und
Feuerwerk dass die Menschen auf ganz
schlimme Ideen kommen können und leider
ist es nicht gelungen im Vorfeld diese
Ideen bei den Menschen abzuwenden und
die gruppendynamischen Prozesse die auch
wissenschaftlich erklärbar sind lösen so
etwas auf es macht fassungslos und
betroffen und deswegen brauchen wir
nicht nur die Diskussion um Verbesserung
und ein anderes Silvester sondern wir
brauchen auch ganz klar die Härte der
Justiz denn das ist etwas Positives es
wurden die Menschen festgenommen die
Übergriffe verübt haben sie haben es
gerade angesprochen im Vorfeld wurde ja
auch schon darüber diskutiert es gab
viele Warnung das Einsatzkräfte von
Polizei auch von Feuerwehr und
Rettungsdiensten akut gefährdet sind
trotzdem gab es zum Beispiel kein
böllerverbot die Politik da versagt hat
sie sozusagen sehenden in Auges in Kauf
genommen was da passiert ist wir sind
zwei Dinge die man betrachten muss es
gab keinen generelles böllerverbot es
ist Aufgabe des Bundesministerium für
inneren hier das Sprengstoffgesetz zu
novellieren anzupacken dass es nicht
geschehen und die Länder insbesondere
Kommunen haben sich mit Verbotszonen
beholfen die mal besser mal schlechter
gewirkt haben viele polizeiliche
Einsatzkonzepte sind aufgegangen dafür
kann man sehr viel Dankbarkeit auch an
die Polizei in richten aber nicht alle
sind aufgegangen und da haben wir
schlimmstes erlebt und ich glaube
deswegen braucht es diese
deutschlandweite Debatte jetzt damit sie
nicht so wie Berliner das auch sagen
kurz vor Silvester erst entsteht und
handlungsunfähig macht ja wir haben am
schlimmsten erlebt sagen sie man geht er
davon aus dass der Staat das
Gewaltmonopol hat angesichts solcher
Bilder fragt man sich ist das überhaupt
noch so genau auf jeden Fall hat er es
wir müssen nur sehr viel erleiden als
polizeibeschäftigte aber jetzt auch im
Feuerwehren Rettungswesen der Stadt hat
das Monopol und setzt es auch durch
deswegen ja auch die Festnahmen aber
diese Festnahme erfolgen natürlich unter
schwersten Bedingungen wir werden
beschossen wir müssen Ausstattung
Ausrüstung haben die höchsten
Temperaturen statthält wir brauchen
brandschutzhauben neben uns explodieren
Geschosse Polenböller und und und und
trotzdem ist der Staat natürlich
wehrhaft wir nehmen diese Menschen fest
aber das Berufsrisiko und das was wir
erlebt haben ist natürlich enorm hoch
aber dafür brauchen wir die Diskussion
die Verbesserung sie sind für ein
böllerverbot auch gegen den Verkauf was
sagen sie zum Gegenargument das dann
häufig hervorgebracht wird damit das
dann eben auch alle vernünftigen
bestraft würden
ich glaube das Problem ist wenn man
nicht über ein generelles Verbot spricht
dann erleben wir wieder einen Flicken
Teppich in der Bundesrepublik der
Föderalismus hat Vorteile aber auch
gravierende Nachteile insbesondere im
polizeilichenbereich und wenn man in
einem Teil Deutschlands Dinge tun darf
von dem anderen Teil nicht dann erleben
wir einen Tourismus hin zu den Gebieten
wo eine andere Rechtslage herrscht
sofern braucht es eine deutschlandweite
Debatte und auch einen Kompromiss in
dieser Frage ich halte das böllerverbot
und auch die Frage wer wem Böller
zugänglich sind oder Pyrotechnik für
angebracht und sehe da auch tatsächlich
die Notwendigkeit hier in Berlin fordern
manche Politiker jetzt die Ausweitung
von Böller Verbotszonen was würde das
bringen ihre Einschätzung nach ja
böllerverbotszonen müssen kontrolliert
werden es ist richtig sie zu fordern es
ist falsch zu sagen man kann sie nicht
bringen weil sie nicht kontrollierbar
sind weil natürlich die Idee nicht davon
abhängig gemacht werden darf wie viel
Polizei zur Verfügung steht aber klar
ist wenn der personalkörper von
Sicherheitskräften stark gut aufgestellt
Geld nicht durch Krankheit Urlaub oder
Übergriffe geschwächt ist dann sind wir
auch polizeilich in der Lage aber noch
mal der Kräfteansatz für die
Neujahrsnacht ist schon enorm und
fordert möglicherweise in Zukunft noch
mehr Polizisten im Polizisten und das
kann es natürlich nicht sein also
braucht es viele gute Ideen die eine
Verbesserung und ein schönes friedvolles
fest herbeirufen
dem Vorsitzenden der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei vielen Dank nach Bremen
dankeschön